un ángulo cuya tangente es un medio es
0.46 radiales nos están indicando que la
tangente aquí la tangente del ángulo que
termina en esta línea vamos a escribir
lo vamos a escribirlo con el mismo color
la tangente de 0.46 radiales es igual a
un medio otra manera de ver esto es que
la pendiente del lado terminal del
ángulo es un medio y si efectivamente
parece que la pendiente de esta recta es
un medio ahora que otros ángulos tienen
tangente igual a un medio veamos las
opciones
este es el ángulo original de 0.46
radiales más y medios si lo quieres ver
en grados que son 180 grados y sobre 2
son 90 grados si lo vemos en la gráfica
vamos a poner lo mejor con este color
para que se note si lo vemos en la
gráfica más o menos por aquí
tendríamos un ángulo que mide y sobre 2
así es que este sería y sobre 2.46 y la
pendiente de esta recta no es igual a la
pendiente de esta otra recta de hecho
estas dos rectas son perpendiculares el
ángulo que forman entre ellas es depp y
medios pero definitivamente no tienen la
misma tangente no tienen la misma
pendiente ahora consideremos pi menos
0.46 pies el ángulo desde la parte
positiva hasta la parte negativa del eje
x y si le restamos 0.46 más o menos más
o menos vendría por aquí
éste sería pi menos 0.46 que es el
ángulo que hemos restado aquí otra
manera de ver esto es que si tomas el
radio terminal de 0.46 y lo reflejas a
través del eje y vas a obtener el radio
terminal de pi menos 0.46 y aquí podemos
ver que la pendiente de este nuevo rayo
terminal es distinta a la pendiente del
radio terminal original de hecho
parecería que una pendiente es la
negativa de la otra así
que éste también lo podemos eliminar
0.46 más para opi 0.46 es decir a partir
del lado terminal de 0.46 vamos a sumar
pi que es el ángulo que corresponde al
recorrer media circunferencia éste es pi
más 0.46 vamos a indicarlo aquí este de
aquí es el ángulo correspondiente a pi
más 0.46 y si te fijas este lado
terminal es co lineal con el lado
terminal de 0.46 ambos se ubican sobre
la misma recta que tiene pendiente de un
medio por lo cual los ángulos tienen la
misma tangente así es que este ángulo
también tiene una tangente de un medio y
en un vídeo previo donde hablamos de
simetrías para la tangente mostramos eso
que si al ángulo le sumábamos pi
obteníamos el mismo valor de la tangente
si te interesa profundizar en esto te
invito a que revises el vídeo simetrías
en el círculo unitario para la tangente
veamos las otras opciones
0.46 2 0.46 2 p si la parte positiva del
eje x son cero grados
dos pi es una vuelta completa te lleva
de regreso a la parte positiva del eje x
y xi ahora restamos un ángulo de 0.46
vamos a obtener este lado terminal y ese
rayo parece que tiene la pendiente
negativa del rayo original así es que
este ángulo no va a tener la tangente de
un medio chequeamos ahora este último al
ángulo de 0.46 le estamos sumando dos pi
aquí tenemos 0.46 y le estamos dando una
vuelta completa al círculo unitario y
estamos llegando precisamente al punto
de partida es decir al sumar dos pi a un
ángulo no tan sólo vas a obtener el
mismo valor de tangente vas a obtener el
mismo valor de seno y el mismo valor de
coseno pues básicamente se regresa al
mismo ángulo cuando sumas dos pi
así es que definitivamente este ángulo
también tiene tangente un medio y así
hemos concluido